Fox News Alert Attorney General William
bar telling Congress it will be sent he
will send them the 400 page molar report
by mid-april if not sooner Barr saying
that portions of the special counsels
findings they're going to have to be
redacted including material subjective
criminal procedures and intelligence
community sources and methods the
Attorney General adding that the White
House will not be reviewing the report
before it's sent to Capitol Hill and
this is part is getting a lot of
attention Barr saying some are
mischaracterizing his four page summary
he says the summary was only about
principle conclusions and nothing more
wire also said he is willing to testify
before Congress after the report is made
public and he gave them a couple of
dates for that
president Trump reacting to the news
just moments ago well have confidence in
the Attorney General and if that's what
he'd like to do I have nothing to hide
this was a hoax this was a witch-hunt
I have absolutely nothing to hide
and I think a lot of things are coming
out with respect to the other side but I
have a lot of confidence in the Attorney
General all right Jesse this is getting
a lot of attention because when this
week we've been reporting that the
Justice Department says it will be weeks
not months that people will get to see
this full report but now we know it's
really just a couple of weeks it's not
like eight weeks and then the Attorney
General said and I'm willing to come up
and explain it all to you I will testify
in front of Congress and still chairman
Nadler he's mad right bars a total Pro
he's got his eyes on the road got the
hands on the wheel and Democrats yeah
Kratz the kids in the back are we there
yet are we there yet worried that he's
not even listening he's just gonna get
to the destination well this car won't
make me pull this car over kids he's
doing everything by the book I think he
has impeccable credentials and the
Democrats really setting themselves up
for even more disappointment when they
do see as much as they can and there
still is no collusion I'm kind of
confused as to what they're actually
alleging is going on like Barr is in a
criminal conspiracy to cover up rush a
collision with rod Rosen Stein and the
rest of the Department of Justice I just
don't think that's true can we make a
trip down what about ISM Lane and okay
take the wheel how about when Hillary
bleached 30,000 emails or destroyed all
of the blackberries with a hammer or
when her husband met with the woman
investigating her on a tarmac and
everybody pled the fifth and everybody
got immunity deals permission to go a
little farther down okay how about when
the IRS destroyed tons of servers or
when the AG at the time holder was held
in contempt for not disclosing all the
information about fast and furious where
all the contractors have been gods were
made to sign NDA's that sounded like a
little bit more of a cover-up than the
evidence of the there's a cover-up going
on right now I would just let the
Democrats remind them what they said
then which was absolutely nothing all
right
Ron I'm gonna give you a chance to
reverse in from that lane if you'd liked
it no time we're gonna stop the metaphor
right there do you think that this gets
the Democrats a little bit closer to
what they need which is that they say
they want to see it they're obviously
concerned that there will be reductions
in regards to material that is subject
to the grand jury or anything that would
hurt a third party that was on
peripheral and also anything that's
intelligence related but this gets him a
little bit closer to where they've
wanted to be well Jerry Nadler the
chairman had a conversation with bill
bar earlier this week and he said he
wasn't satisfied in their conversation
because Barr indicated to him that there
would be redactions in whatever is
released and he said at that time he
thought it would be again mid April
which is what he confirmed in this
letter today but what's the news out of
the letter for people who are looking at
it as Crump critics is that he said that
people are over valuing the earlier
missive which was simply said here's the
bottom line in terms of conspiracy and
obstruction he says it was not intended
to be an exhaustive report on what
Muller had found he says it he in this
letter he says as my letter made clear
my notification of Congress and the
public provided pending release of the
report a summary of its principal
conclusion and that is its bottom line
of course which we know is no collusion
and then on the obstruction piece right
but the thing about that is that it has
provided just to the opportunity to
up and down and take the wheel for the
last week so I think there are a lot of
people who think you know what Bob
William bar I should say has done a
tremendous service to the president and
his supporters because they've allowed
them that is to treat this as if it's
the fate of complete that's all done we
know what the bottom line is when in
fact there may be tremendous amount of
evidence there may be tremendous amount
of testimony although we're good we're
not sure we'll see grand jury testimony
indicating that there was involvement it
just didn't rise to the level of
indictment and prosecution but that's
you know a nuance at this point but
nonetheless I think today is good news I
would say this to people on the left I
don't think that you should get excited
and expect that you know you got to dial
back your expectations I don't think
it's gonna be damning even in the full
report and people on the right I would
say dial back the idea that you think as
president Trump says this is total
vindication because I don't think that's
what's community are you dialing up or
dulling down dialing back forward
reverse I I'm in neutral most of these
things because I have very low
expectations of government officials by
and large and I am I'm never surprised
by the process or the ability of either
side to politicize even the tiniest
piece of news but what I will say about
William bar I don't share your universal
blanket of love for the Attorney General
you know he said he's a fine picky
he wasn't my first choice he's got some
issues in his past this must be a very
different time from when he served under
George HW Bush he must be just
overwhelmed I would say he's better than
Jeff session but I don't see why he
would completely undermine his own
reputation by putting out a false
summary of the Moller report that that
does not serve him at all and the
slightest and he's also not someone he
said he's not going to seek the
presidency it doesn't seem as though
he's got these grand political
aspirations and also Special Counsel is
helping with the redactions and if this
were so completely counter to what
Robert Muller and his team had been
doing last years they would have come
out because they're done they would have
come out and said no no no that is a
mischaracterization and they are working
on the results Greg we gave you some
time to get revved up ready for why
would I need time Dana I don't know are
you suggesting that there's something
going on with me
I know that you wanted to digest this
information you using the word digest is
unfair I might have a little issue right
now that is not the public's business
and I would refrain from bringing it up
again
look this all this news is basically
table scraps for a bitter media where
you will see redactions they will scream
conspiracy though Rachel Maddow will
break out the whiteboard because this is
their business model I predict not only
will they find collusion and obstruction
they will get find the location of
Bigfoot and a lost city of Atlantis
which I believe it's somewhere outside
Denver so this is going to keep going
because the media wants to keep this
going because it's their business model
and who benefits from this Russia
because let's not forget the primary
goal of Russia was to undermine our
institutions
it wasn't about electing Trump it wasn't
about electing anybody it was about
screwing with our mentality making us
question everything
yeah and foment chaos and who's
fulfilling the Russians goal media and
the Democrats except the ones that one
is correct the ones that dial back their
expectations and move on are doing the
right thing you know what I would say at
this moment bill Barr is so much the
focus of all our attention and Bill Barr
you got to remember from at least from
my perspective campaign for this job
and said that he believed an extensive
presidential power I don't know he wrote
a letter Dana are you suggesting that
there's a politician I'm gonna go
further have you ever seen mr. Barr and
Steve banning together at the same time
I think banner with glasses no no no I
think he ate him permission allowed I
think bill bar as a former attorney
general who did not anticipate going
back he I don't think he was applying
for the drug don't want to necessarily
leave like his life as he had it to go
back into government yeah to the Trump
campaign but he's a lawyer he's a
lawyers lawyer he's like I've got some
thoughts on this jots him down and sends
him over it would be like let's say that
if I didn't have
the job that I have now but I was in a
PR practice and I was like you know I'd
have some advice and thoughts for Sarah
Sanders I'm just going to shoot her a
little letter and and there's a sound
like I am campaigning to be in a job no
but you've written two books and one of
them was largely about your time as
press secretary for the presidents and
they're still available on Amazon by the
way named Jasper in case you guys are
forgotten wrote a letter and sent it to
the White House Counsel that's involved
directly in this matter Dana I think
that takes it to a different level well
maybe he will have to answer such a
question it goes all the way to the top
Dana all the way to the top all the way
to space aliens Bigfoot she's gonna yell
at me